un soir que j'étais sur la scène une
bande de jeunes con ma tenue des propos
de scène pour que j'en fasse une chanson
il en est pas question
[Musique]
c'est une fierté nationale entre nous et
pas mal elle ouvre les pages
je suis choqué je suis outré comment
peut-on à ce point-là me manquer le
respect comment peut-on imaginer que des
gens puissent écouter ça et encore plus
imaginer que les gens puissent chanter
ça c'est pas comme
[Musique]
ça
c'est l'ouvre ses pages
et même si ça fait scandale montre-nous
tes pas mal c'est pas des pages
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
choqué je suis blessé comment peut-on à
ce point-là attaquer la fierté encore
les plus codéfinés le jour du 14 juillet
une musique militaire tout ça sur les
Champs-Élysées
[Musique]
et on chante
se refrain et que même le président le
chantant avant dans les mains attention
là-bas ici
[Musique]
fais nous
voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà
[Applaudissements]